you went all in
why
because it was fun
truthfully
honestly like hand to god
it was the most fun like every single
day i wake up and i'm like what are we
talking about today what am i doing
today people are like oh how do you post
consistently on instagram i'm like like
the things you're talking about it's
hard to then not to it's hard to then
not to connect with your community how
do you stay consistent on youtube
because i want to talk to my community i
want to talk about what's happening i
find myself
pulling back to take breaks
is much harder than pulling me towards
making content and once i found that
leaning in towards content was exactly
my happy place i was like i am all in i
will figure it out
going full time on youtube and building
your channel to over a hundred thousand
subscribers today i'm going to interview
emily baker a youtube content creator
and lawyer and we're going to be talking
about the three ways that she was able
to build her youtube channel going live
and building her community my name is
heather torres and i am the host of the
think media podcast the number one
podcast to help you grow your youtube
channel and then turn that youtube
channel into a high profit and a high
impact online business and each and
every episode we love to bring you some
of our favorite brands who are
partnering with us here on our podcast
and on our main channel and today i want
to talk to you about podcasts if you're
going to start a podcast this year and
you want to be able to conduct
interviews podcasts might be the right
solution for you you can share a link
with up to nine guests and they can
immediately start recording using their
own computers there's no extra equipment
or downloads required with each guest
and their own locally recorded studio
quality tracks editing is a breeze you
can split trim fade and arrange each
track to your heart's content then you
can use podcastl's ai-powered magic desk
tool to automatically sweeten and
equalize the mix so it sounds amazing
you can invite record edit and polish
all in a day's work with podcasts you
can start recording your podcast today
just go to podcastwiththink.com
if you are brand new to this podcast i
want to welcome you thank you so much
for being a part of what we're doing
here at think media and today we're
going to interview emily baker now let
me tell you a little bit about who emily
is and then jump into today's episode
emily is a licensed attorney for over 15
years who breaks down the legal side of
pop culture and news stories we all want
to talk about she hosts a legal
commentary show that helps you
understand the law with humor curse
words and creating a thriving community
called the lot nerds her channel is over
200 000 subscribers and 20 million views
with some of her most popular videos
being over two hours long in today's
episode we're gonna be breaking down
exactly how she did it and
some exciting news is that emily's
actually going to be one of our speakers
at grow with video live this year i'll
tell you more about that after the
featured content
[Music]
emily i'm so excited that you're on the
podcast today thank you so much i would
love for the think community to really
just hear your story and how you got
started on youtube absolutely i started
on youtube when i was going through
health problems so i was having health
issues and back surgeries i was still
working as a deputy district attorney in
la and i started doing tech content
because that's the community on youtube
that i really enjoyed and i wanted to be
like a tech tuber i was like i want to
talk about iphones and i want to talk
about all the things and i started
creating video content just around my
phone and then around kind of the
struggles i was going through i i might
have done a few like unboxings some like
what's in my bag they were very popular
in 2017 2018 yeah and
as i transitioned away from the da's
office i transitioned into working with
online business owners as a legal
consultant i'm an attorney i've been an
attorney gosh i'm 16 years at this point
and when i was doing that i started
creating content that would be like a
library or an evergreen place where when
people ask me questions i could be like
oh go here and that was my podcast it
was really geared towards entrepreneurs
in the online business space and the
legal side of it what's going on with
independent contractors and how do you
hire people and all that stuff
and then
as 2020 hit
and the podcast was doing well and my
clients were like oh my god
everything is crazy i'm not at school
with my like my kids aren't at school
and i'm homeschooling and distance
learning and i don't know what's going
to happen with my business and really
stopping doing business
i was like oh
where where do i want to spend my time
because then i had a choice and it was
really content i loved the podcast i
missed doing youtube content i had been
struggling to find where
youtube matched with like my business
like where's youtube with your business
and i was like i just missed creating
content and so i started taking what i
was doing on the podcast and really
expanding it to talk about legal stories
because i loved talking about legal
stories and nobody in my immediate life
wanted to talk about that they're like i
don't care that kanye west is like
putting his music contracts on the
internet like who cares and i'm like i
want to talk about it and so i started
talking more and more
like legal commentary that's not really
what i intended i just wanted to be like
oh my god this is crazy
and then things kept happening um stuff
happened on youtube i started talking
about toddy westbrook's multiple
lawsuits things were happening off
youtube erica girardi and real
housewives with legal drama and
indictments and it just blew up from
there but it was a really interesting
path of tweaking it to find where it fit
but i always loved creating content and
coming back to that and then really
dialing in where it fit in my life
made my youtube channel now the number
one thing that i do so i went from
los angeles county deputy district
attorney to lawyer for online
entrepreneurs to full-time youtuber
content creator oh my goodness i i hope
this encourages the listeners because
one thing in that story is one it didn't
happen overnight no
and two that you actually started
because you wanted to be a tech tuber
yes but really your skill and your
passion and what you were really really
good at was the law and like how do you
bring that into the space you're on so
interesting you said you started your
podcast first and then your youtube
channel so even like getting your feet
wet in content creation in a different
way and you're like i'll keep this over
here and i'll be a tech tuber over here
but actually melding the two together
was where the magic happened it is and
that's where i really shifted because it
i felt like youtube and i took youtube
way too seriously like i took youtube
very seriously like the lights have to
be perfect my edits have to be parked
sound has to be perfect where my podcast
i treated more like a conversation and
it felt so safe to be able to just turn
on a microphone and sit and talk and
i had a couple friends say can you just
do that on youtube and i was like no
it must be perfect and they're like but
you're putting out content once every
three months like drop it being perfect
and just do it and that's when i turned
to live streaming because for me live
streaming bridge the gap between just
sit down and talk and it has to be
perfect and that's when my content
shifted away from like tech and purses
in my life
into
the stuff i was doing on my podcast
which was really legal analysis and
legal commentary so good okay we're
going to get into three tips but before
we do
we are two youtube entrepreneurs uh in
this space and i want to really talk
about that getting started exactly what
you just said about your friends saying
do this on youtube and you thought it
had to be perfect now one of the fears
that i had coming to the platform was
i'm just a normal girl yeah and i don't
wear makeup more than i do wear makeup
and you know those types of things
did you decide when you came to the
platform what you wanted your image to
be on the platform and then we'll get
into the three tips
absolutely let's talk about this for a
second because it it matters i mean it
was one of the things that was
frustrating as a district attorney when
you're in jury trials how you are
perceived by people that you don't know
is a very big part of your case are they
going to be put off by me do i look
tired do i look not put together do i
look frazzled do i look authoritative
and so i had to do that in my legal prof
like professional career and i was
worried about that on youtube too
because again what i loved about doing a
podcast is messy bun mike on go for it
yes and i decided to pull that into
youtube too because i know i'm not gonna
put on makeup every day i have two kids
it's not gonna happen i like being on
instagram and i had done instagram reels
and lives there and so people knew my
face without makeup on without mascara
on with my hair just pulled up or wet
and i wanted to carry that onto youtube
and
while there are days that there is
makeup and hair
looking good they can't see you on film
right now it looks good today there are
so many days there are so many days that
it is not makeup and hair and it it's
because i didn't want
a i didn't want there to be an
expectation but b i wanted my audience
to know that wherever
they are it's fine like it's just it's
real life and there's times i go live
because things have happened and i don't
want to wait to go live to talk about
something because i have to go and get
ready i wanted to be ready to film and
when i was breaching the gap between the
perfection or the perfection i felt
youtube needed
appearance and getting ready was one of
those big things that i was like okay
well if i'm going to do this and it's
going to be sustainable i have to be
comfortable going live and that's
whatever your comfort level is or
whatever level of makeup you want to
wear if you're going to just go live in
mascara do it i've done it it's fine
yeah that is what i love to encourage
our community because that is that is a
piece of what we're doing you know our
appearance and what we're doing i mean
video does matter but at the same time i
think that's what people love about
youtube is kind of that raw that kind of
especially you going live that feeling
of like we're friends and we can we can
hang out on the porch with a glass of
wine and just kind of hang out our
jammies and we're going to have a chat
yeah we're going to we need to talk
about it we're going to have a chat
because if you really are like oh my god
this just happened i want to talk about
it
my i don't think my audience is like oh
emily's looking a little tired today i
think they're like oh my god what's
happening and
i needed to i needed to break that down
for me too because again i had spent so
many years treating youtube way too
precious and being so worried that every
video wasn't gonna be perfect that i was
like you know what it doesn't have to be
perfect that's me that's me worrying
about it not being perfect that's my own
judgment i've never watched a channel
and been like oh my god that creator
looks like this way or that way i want
to see their video and i want to see
what they're talking about i i don't
judge that so why do i think other was
would judge me on that and if they do
they're probably not my ideal audience
anyway mm-hmm i love that point and
let's get into some of the tips so you
grew your channel uh walk me through the
journey because you're not brand new to
youtube you've been on this platform
trying different things experimenting
trying to figure out what your it thing
was and uh walk us through kind of that
journey of you started you were growing
now you are at uh you know over almost
two you're almost to two hundred
thousand almost a hundred thousand yeah
when they're listening to this at two
hundred thousand walk me through the
journey though of um how you've been
pivoting your channel absolutely so when
i started on youtube
it really i was still a district
attorney and i was looking for community
and i loved the tech space and i wanted
to talk about it because again people at
work didn't care like getting my first
iphone was life-changing to me i was
like
it's my first iphone so when i started
on youtube my first video was in like
june 2015.
fast forward to october 2020 kanye west
is on twitter releasing all of his legal
documents and i'm like oh my god like
these are hundreds and thousands of
dollars worth of contracts nobody gets
to see like behind the scenes like this
and i recorded like a vertical video on
instagram and then uploaded it to
youtube kill me now it's a vertical live
stream from instagram on youtube but i
did it it was like fine i mean i might
have had a friend going just upload it
just upload it it's fine
but i was sitting
around 4 000 subscribers at that point
and that's when i started going live
because i was like i don't have time to
read all these documents then from a
video then edit it then get feedback
from my custom my customers my audience
and then go back and re
recreate another video to answer all
those questions when i can just live
stream so i started live streaming in
october 2020 on youtube at the end of
october i remember on halloween
celebrating with my kids that we had hit
5 000 subscribers and i was stoked
and then a case i was covering took off
in november and we grew like 55 000
subscribers in november which was insane
because my live streams went from
you know
30 people 50 people 200 people 300
people to 3 000 5 000 7 000 and it got
fast like i was like what i need
moderators like i've never had
moderators in my life like what do we do
and so the channel took off in november
and kept growing and we i just kept
making content kept going live
and we hit a hundred thousand in may
that's when i dyed my hair purple
um because i had made a joke on a live
stream and when you make a joke on a
live stream you better be ready because
your audience will hold you to it with
video evidence they're like you said it
100k you're dying your hair purple i'm
like i did say that we're doing it and
it was really fun um a lot of my
community also dyed their hair purple
tons
of photos and
you know i didn't
my creator journey didn't start until my
late 30s i'm in my 40 early 40s early
40s
now
and
you don't have to be you know a 20 year
old influencer who can dance to create a
career on social media and that's one of
the things my audience love they're like
we love that you embrace who you are
you're a nerd you make jokes you stuff
comes into your head and you say it you
talk i talk about being adhd and
dyslexic because i read things wrong
because everyone who's been adhd and
dyslexic knows reading out loud is like
right
tara reading out loud is terror yes like
my all of my third grade trauma of like
can you read out loud and i'm like
trying to read ahead to figure out where
i'm going to be so i can read it a few
times before i have to read it out loud
now i read legal documents out loud on
the internet
it is what it is but i tell my audience
like look this is why i will
mispronounce things i will misspeak um
and they love it because they're like
i'm
like you being you makes me feel good
being me and i'm like yes i don't want
to tell you what to be or how to be or
how to think i want you to know that you
can just be you
and that took me 40 years to learn and i
wish i had learned it a little bit
faster wow wow wow wow wow that's all i
can say i'm dyslexic too
and i have to read off the teleprompter
and every time
every time every time i'm like am i
going to mess this up and i i do i do i
mess it up all the time okay and um i
love that i have a fellow creator that
understands the struggle of you know not
being able to do those things actually
not not being able but being okay that
it's who we are it's it is and that is
just how we are in producing content so
so i wear the glasses i wear for those
that have watched my content my glasses
actually help with my light sensitivity
and dyslexia so there's times people
come in and they're like is she wearing
sunglasses and
my someone in the lunar community will
be like actually those are emily's
ireland lenses and she wears them for
this and people be like wait that's a
thing like i didn't know that was a
resource that might be available to me
too
and that's why i don't you know people
are like you could get contacts i'm like
no
this is who i am and this is what helps
me so it just is a few people who are
like oh that's weird they can go bono
has erland lenses they're red it's great
so
and i share it because if you share with
your audience
they can share their experiences back
with you and the amount of particularly
women
um that have been diagnosed with add in
their 30s and 40s have reached out and
like i understand my kids better because
both of my kids are also adhd i
understand my kids better and i
understand myself better and i wouldn't
have known if you hadn't shared
and that's how we learn we share yeah
wow and so with that one of the tips or
one of the ways that you grew to 100 000
was by going live yes and a lot of
people are scared of going live it is
scary i mean if you get started i'm used
to it now but at the beginning i would
mess up so much and i'd be like during
the headlights but you're just flipping
on the camera and going live so let's
talk about that and you're not going
live for 10 minutes or 15 minutes emily
is like grab your popcorn grab your soda
let's get your dinner let's do the whole
thing whiskey because they're like two
hours three hours long serving your
community live let's talk about why you
decided live and i know you said a
little bit because of just kind of time
but really this is a strategy that
you've kept with as your channel's been
growing i love live streaming and i
don't know if it's because of my
background as a trial lawyer but even in
high school like i loved model un i did
model u1 and it was very there's live
feedback and that is something that
energizes me and i
really want to know if my audience isn't
understanding what i'm saying in a legal
document i know real time because i'll
see it in the chat like explain this
explain this i'm like oh i didn't break
that term down and i can just do it in
real time to make sure that
my content is helping my audience
understand what i'm explaining but also
it's just a lot of fun
to live stream and i take
i take it i don't i take it really
seriously i have a whole formula for how
i live stream but it doesn't feel as
formal to me to just flip on a camera
and live stream i will misspeak um i
will be like oh my god i said this and
it says like there was a time i i said
something was like oh it's like 300 000
and they're like emily that's just 300
million and i was like oh
but i don't have to go edit back a video
i can just fix it in real time and i
love connecting with my community in
that way i also love seeing them connect
with each other and i can see like them
having conversations in the chat which
doesn't bother me because when i'm just
doing content i'm not looking at the
chat because i'll get distracted and
i'll live stream for five hours by
accident i did four once and i was like
my moderator's like emily it's been four
hours i'm like oh my god i'm sorry
we all have things to do today but
it really was a way for me to break
through my own perfectionism and not
worry about it and to get the content
out faster and i
love
live streaming and people really give
grace in live streams they know that
you're live and your audience gives
grace they're not expecting something to
be highly produced and perfectly edited
they want to hear you and
i treat it i mean when i look at live
streaming i really do treat it like a
like a concert
the thing i hate most in live streaming
people do this all the time
you know what i'm going to say they get
in and they're like hey
just going gonna wait for a few more of
you to get in look
look i have never been to a concert
where the band comes on stage and looks
out at the seats and it's like hey
there's a few seats they're empty i'm
gonna wait for them to sit down and then
we're gonna get started i'm just gonna
we're just gonna chat here make sure
everything looks good all the people
that are there feel so disrespected
they're like what i'm not important
enough i my live streams start when they
start like the second i'm live we start
yeah everybody will just come in they
don't need to be told to come on in it's
fine i hate it so much that is such a
good tip no it's such a good tip because
that that's one thing we're like and
even for the replay value of that live
stream you don't want 10 minutes of you
talking about your day and your cat and
your you know what i do those things i
do sometimes do those things too but but
i chapter my live stream yeah so if you
don't want to be here for the welcome
where i'm telling people what we're
going to cover
um what the topics are if there is a
little story i will tell them that but
part of that is
for me to get into my content and chat
with my audience and also some of it's
because i love seeing where they're
coming in from and so we have it
where they know that my content goes
like that yeah but also i don't play
i don't play a 30 second countdown
before i go live i don't play my intro
at the beginning of going live i go live
and i start talking and then i chapter
it for the replay because the replay
value on live streams is huge
if you do it right
if you don't do it right people are like
huh
yes yeah yeah and and that is that's
just understanding how youtube works is
really good now you i want to go back
because you said you were making this
type of tech content and then you
switched into what you were doing on
your podcast brought it to youtube and
one of the ways that you grew was by
doing what we call here at think media
trend surfing and influence surfing and
really you were covering from your legal
perspective these types of um of cases
is that what you would call these types
of cases now here's the thing that
someone's going to say well someone's
already doing what i'm doing there's
other lawyers on youtube there's plenty
of other lawyers on youtube there's lots
of them there's a whole lawtube
community and then there's you know big
lawyers like legal eagle who do this
stuff on youtube but there's only one
emily d baker yes and
you love pop culture you love this type
of thing so you're bringing those two
things so one of the ways you grew how
do you decide what you want to cover
what how how did you know that you're
like i actually do want to go down this
road
of kanye west and um name some other of
people that randy spears real housewives
josh duggar toddy westbrook i love pop
culture and it's
the thing is when i i go a lot by
feeling and how i feel about content if
it's a story that if you called me up
and were like emily
this and i'm like girl yes and this that
is content i want to cover if i read the
story and i'm like um
i don't like any of that i don't want to
talk about it live multiple times i
don't want to be asked questions about
it live so when i started narrowing down
what i was doing i will cover some
kind of more traditional hard news
topics that are legally related trials
that are going on but i pick things that
i can help people understand and
evaluate and decide for themselves so if
the media is all reporting a particular
trial one way and i see it different
because i'm watching what's happening in
the courtroom that i'm like there's
something i can help bridge the gap here
on but i love pop culture the most so i
talk about pop culture the most because
that's what i'm excited about and when
you know people magazine or abc or
insider reaches out and i was like can
we talk about this i'm never like ugh
another conversation about that i'm
always like yes please i want to talk
about this all the time like if we
started talking about jen shaw right now
we would be here for another hour we'll
do that when we're done with the podcast
because i love the stuff that i'm
talking about and that's how i choose
yes what
excites me because i know there's others
out there that want to talk about it as
well and it lets me be a resource for
other content creators too because
there's plenty of content creators
talking about bravo there aren't a ton
of lawyers there are a group of us but
there aren't a ton of lawyers talking
about bravo so i can now be a resource
to bring the legal understanding to the
pop culture stories that it's like oh my
god but they said this on twitter and
they said that i'm like yes and in the
court filings it said this and that
and that lets me collab with other
creators too which is really fun because
i'm not competing with anyone if you
want to watch hard news legal go do it
if you want to see highly produced legal
that's like law school and it's going to
be like well it came from this case
starting back here go watch legal eagle
there's it's great there's graphics
there's you know shorts
none of my stuff is short
yeah if you want to deep dive into
britney spears's conservatorship i got
you
i love that so much and i think it's so
good for content creators of all kinds
even coming from professional
backgrounds knowing that you can put
your own spin on it and that one of the
ways to do that is by trend surfing is
my influencer influencer serving if
you're into that you know like for me
personally that is a hard thing for me
to get into because i i'm like what are
the trends what are the influences but
you tell me to teach a specific skill
and i'm like i got you i can do that so
every content creator can come to the
platform and do their own thing and i
love that you've really carved out this
space and one of the things you've done
with carving out the space is creating
community and i think that a lot of
content creators undervalue how
important their community is and we were
talking before the podcast how uh
content creators like how can i be
everywhere and actually your strategy i
think is really key of how you even grew
to a hundred thousand beyond a hundred
thousand and now opening up um you know
opening up an entire business world into
what you're able to do on your channel
so let's talk about that a little bit
absolutely tell me how important
community is how did you develop your
community and what are some tips for
some people i'm gonna forget the third
one by the time we get there you're
gonna just have to come back and remind
me because i i love talking about my
community um community is everything
community is more important to me than
subscriber numbers than any of my
analytics
if my community is doing well i am doing
well as a creator because
my community is literally my happiest
place to be on the internet and i think
that's what gives people hesitation
about going live is they're worried
about being trolled they're worried
about being harassed and for creators
for all different kinds of creators
um that's a real concern and a real fear
and it does happen on platforms we've
seen um even recently large streamers
get harassed and people get you know
yeted off of twitch because of it you
don't want that experience and it's
really uncomfortable live to be like
what's happening this is uncomfortable
but when you build a community it weeds
it out if i see somebody starting to
troll my community will either ignore
them or will alert my mods and be like
hey we're seeing these comments they're
trolling and then they can just be
excused right off of my live stream so i
don't ever feel
like if i'm going live i have to worry
about oh what's somebody gonna say it's
not a concern and youtube gives such
great tools for that you can do
subscribers only mode you could do
members only mode you can really control
how you stream and community is a big
part of that because they take on your
values as a creator and so we have rules
for my live stream and people have come
onto me like why do you have so many
rules on your live stream i'm like do
you see what a pleasant place this is a
chat yeah this is like an aol chat room
circa like 1997. yes this is what this
chat is like this is not thunderdome in
here if you want to go have a
thunderdome chat go to twitch have fun
insult each other all day long that's
not what we do yeah and that's not what
i want as a creator
and i love it because i see it not just
on
youtube but i see it on the way they
engage on instagram and on twitter as
well and in the comments as well so the
live stream becomes an event because
people want to talk to the other members
in their community they're not just
there for me live they're also there to
talk to each other i would rather be in
a few places and keep my community than
be everywhere and i
you know if people are like oh well you
you did this and you did that in your
moderation i'm like then you're not the
right subscriber for me i'm not after
subscriber numbers i'm here to build the
law nerd community and they named
themselves the honored community i was
going to ask you that because we still
haven't quite figured out what our
community name is and and i love that
they name themselves that's amazing that
is not it's not what i would i mean i
don't know what i would have chosen but
my podcast had gotten renamed but it had
been uh the get legit podcast and so it
was like legit crew and the crew
as it shifted because it was about
business owners becoming legit but as
that shifted the law nerds are like but
we're not here to get our businesses
legit we're here to talk about the t in
these filings
and i'm a giant nerd i mean i have star
wars tattoos i am a massive nerd i am a
fan girl of multiple fandoms i have like
tardis's in the background in my in my
youtube videos yeah and most of the
people that came are like no i'm a nerd
too and i didn't know i was nerdy about
law i knew i was nerdy about bravo or
nerdy about you know this or that and
they named themselves on a live stream
they're like no we're the law nerds here
and i was like you are you are the law
nerds and now if i stream anywhere i
will see them pop up in the chat we use
purple hearts after the purple hair and
i will see them pop up around the
internet i know when the lawners are in
the building and they will let everyone
else know when they're in the building
too that is amazing and not even just
like you've created a community you've
created people who
literally like love you no we've gotten
like fandom yeah like we're beyond
community into fandom and i love it like
i feel like i'm part of the fandom too
like a like a supernatural fandom or
like a doctor who fandom we are a fandom
of law nerds and
i love that because now
when they see things that they think i'm
interested in they will send them to me
on twitter so when you look at oh how do
i know what people are talking about
when you have a community they will tell
you what they're talking about and ask
you to join the conversation it takes
all the stress off of it lawnerds should
we talk about this or should we talk
about that and they're like this perfect
so you know you're creating the content
that they want yeah because they if you
build a community they will tell you
what they want so so good so if
someone's getting started on youtube i
love how you said the numbers actually
weren't what you were after and you
could tell because this has been a
journey for you it wasn't like you came
to youtube stress out trying to figure
it out you were like i'm gonna make this
perfect and then i'm gonna learn that it
doesn't have to be perfect and you go
through this journey but if someone's
just starting because i think building
community is such a huge piece it's
critical what did you do i know it's
just who you are also i think it's part
of your intuition to just be really
friendly with people and and and really
uh have people in your world but what
would you give advice to new youtubers
who need to build community like you
have
you have to decide what you want to be a
part of
and i was trying to build what i wanted
to be a part of and that started at
i wanted to be a part of techtube
because i was still a lawyer i couldn't
talk about lawyer things but i wanted to
have conversations with people about the
things that i was interested in
and so i think for new youtubers i see a
lot of people trying to be like oh
should i do a gaming channel do you like
gaming well no but these are growing
well if you don't like it
don't just chase what's trending on
youtube
chase your curiosity chase your passion
chase what you want to talk about and
you will build a community that also
wants to talk about that i have a friend
i think sean has met i don't know have
you met warren for mock donation no so
warren for mock donation runs the
world's largest octopus fan club octopus
octane yes like optimum is like
increasing
the ocean got it hundreds of thousands
of followers across social media awesome
because he's a nerd about octopus and he
was like other people should be nerdy
about octopus they're amazing they do
all these things and i was like
octopus
and they have a their community is
insane like tattoos insane in a good way
but tattoos and uh their own kind of
language and their own merch and it is a
fandom
around octopus
there is room for anything you want to
be a fan of you want to be in the fanfic
community perfect there's people for you
so lean into you as a creator don't just
chase oh this is what's you know beauty
is hot on you well pewdie's kind of
on youtube right now but beauty is hot
on youtube so i'm gonna do beauty
tutorials
no
not unless that's what you love
build a community around what you love
because there are other people out there
who love it too no matter how niche it
is you want to you want to create goat
like a goat farm in your backyard i
guarantee you there is a community for
it you know yeah i say um in my new book
i say uh when you're picking your thing
uh remember when you were in high school
and there was lunch tables and like you
knew like the jocks were there the nerds
were there like you knew and that's kind
of a stereotype but it feels like that
no i sat with the band kids right the
band kids exactly i i was actually with
the cheerleaders random i know but but
uh when you go to youtube your people
are already sitting at the lunch table
having the conversation and now you just
get to join them in the conversation but
you gotta pick your table yeah i think
that's the thing that people try and do
is they try and sit at too many tables
and you're like no no this is the law
nerds and we are here and we are talking
all about this and they really start to
get into the community aspect of it and
you don't have to be afraid like with
within
law and pop culture there is so much and
that's one of the things that helped my
channel grow is i get to tap into other
communities too but i knew where i was i
break down pop culture legal stuff that
everybody's talking about that are
topical i'm not going back and doing
true crime because there's tons of
people that do true crime and my
audience is like hey are you doing true
crime no i don't do true crime i am
doing
the legal in the pop culture sphere
that is happening currently if you're
going to set yourself up though for
current events just beware sometimes it
will derail your plans you're just like
oh that's popping off today wonderful
which is really actually kind of fun
because i get energized by it but
it allows me to say this is what i do
but then
pop culture can be bravo
there are tons of bravo creators that
just break down bravo the shows what
people are saying on social but now we
can chat about the legal documents or
the duggars the duggar community and the
bravo community are two very different
communities but
he got indicted and got prosecuted and
we can have a conversation about what
that prosecution's like same with
britney spears there's a whole free
britney community there's some crossover
with bravo but not always and we can
have that conversation so it allowed me
standing in where i was also allows me
to be a resource in other communities
and that's the same with teaching
youtube you can teach a tech tuber or a
beauty youtuber or a homeschooling
youtuber or a knitting channel
and and it allows you to be like i am
here but it pulls the spokes into the
wheel yeah yeah so good and then lastly
uh i want to wrap up with this you went
all in on youtube yes and i think that
when people move from the dabbling
into no i'm going to dominate this i'm
going to be the number one lawyer on
youtube i'm gonna be the girl i'm gonna
do i'm everybody's favorite legal legal
still has more subscribers
i think i have more of a fandom
yeah it's okay devon don't worry about
it but you went all in yeah let's talk
about that decision to go all in because
it's a big deal to say like i could be
doing this professional thing over here
i could be in the courtroom i could be
you know counseling businesses or
consulting with businesses i could be
doing that i'm going to go all in on
youtube and again our age also is like
your youtuber like you know that that
yes
but you went all in
why
because it was fun
truthfully
honestly like hand to god
it was the most fun like every single
day i wake up and i'm like what are we
talking about today what am i doing
today people are like oh how do you post
consistently on instagram i'm like like
the things you're talking about it's
hard to then not to it's hard to then
not to connect with your community how
do you stay consistent on youtube
because i want to talk to my community i
want to talk about what's happening i
find myself
pulling back to take breaks
is much harder than pulling me towards
making content and once i found that
leaning in towards content was exactly
my happy place i was like i am all in i
will figure it out and i my husband's
like
i remember we were driving my oldest to
school and there are these beautiful
country roads because we moved from los
angeles to tennessee and i love the
country roads so we're driving to school
and he's like okay so you want to narrow
it down because it's like law is pretty
big and i really didn't want to talk
about at the time mostly politics like
there's lawsuits over elections and all
this stuff he's like you really want to
narrow down to pop culture i'm like yes
he's like what are you gonna do when you
run out of stuff to talk about i need
three of me to talk about everything
that's going on and it was just funny
sitting there going no there's there's
enough there's enough people that are
interested and there's enough and
youtube is more i mean lucrative than my
legal career was but i also chose to
work for the government so there's that
but
it's been freeing and it's been the most
fun and so when my days are filled with
joy of like oh my god i get to talk
about this the most stressful part of it
is when there are too many things going
on at once narrowing them down and
that's when i end up with a four-hour
livestream and my moderator's going what
have you done i'm like okay
i couldn't pick today it's like how do
you pick your favorite child i'm talking
to all of them today and that's it we're
going to be here for four hours
they're like you could just stream
multiple days in a row i'm like no we're
here yeah let's go yeah and that's the
hardest part but it was really it was
it's fun and youtube has been
a great place to grow the monetization
has been great the advertisers love
being able to advertise on both my
podcast and on youtube
memberships on youtube are so easy as my
channel started to grow people are
people ask can we do members only live
streams i'm like i guess we need
memberships wow
we'll do that and then that grew and
then they were like can we do even more
i'm like yeah let's go to patreon and
then it was like hey can we get that on
a shirt i'm like oh we have merch now
okay great we've got merch now and
and everything grew with the input of my
community and it takes the pressure off
ask your people what they want and they
will tell you and then do those things
and then show up
so so good i can keep this conversation
going for so long yes i talk quite a lot
i'm excited because you're actually
going to be one of our speakers at
growth video live this year
so if you want to get more from emily um
on the podcast or in person you
definitely need to come to growth video
live it's happening in may 2022 we're
going to be here in las vegas
and it's going to be an epic uh time you
definitely want to get there and come on
let's get the legal nerds there i'm
going to the law nerds oh sorry
the law nerds always want to know where
can i see you in person this is where we
might have to be like ooh honored meet
up we'll talk about it leonard we'll
talk about it but i'm going to get into
more about the how i did it like the
strategy behind that when you're like
yes but how
you've got to come to grow with video
for the yes but how yes so bring your
questions to growth video live but
before we end emily i just want to say
thank you for the work that you're doing
on youtube thank you for stepping up and
stepping out and just being yourself and
thank you for creating a community that
has a place to love what they love too
you know i think without those spaces
online um people sometimes feel alone
and i think what you've brought to the
platform is fun and entertaining but
also educational and just your heart
that you pour into your community is
just really awesome to see so thank you
for being you um thank you for bringing
all of you and i cannot wait for them to
get to see more of what you have at
growth video live i can't either i love
being
you know i love being live live in
person is on another level and i cannot
wait so thank you for having me and
thank you for having me grow with video
live
okay wait
well i hoped you liked that interview
with emily baker and let me know if
you're watching on youtube what other
content creators would you like me to
interview here on the podcast i love
being able to bring amazing content
creators like emily here on the podcast
and if you have questions let me know
down in the comments if you're watching
on youtube or if you are over on apple
podcast
you can write and review the podcast you
can leave your questions or you can let
us know what was your favorite episode
over there and when you do that you're
actually helping us get this podcast
into more people's ears and i'm so
excited to announce that we're actually
in the top 25 of marketing podcasts in
the us that's such a cool accomplishment
and it's all thanks to you so if you
have not already rated and reviewed the
podcast i would love for you to do that
next every single week i love to read
one of the podcast listeners who have
done this already and today is
risingsuns89 rising sun says advice and
insight is unmatched wow thank you uh
it's been i've been listening to this
podcast for almost two years now and i
finally started my youtube channel a few
months ago trust me the advice and
insights they offer is truly unmatched
thank you think media well raising sense
i will make sure that our entire team
sees this because we want to celebrate
you for finally starting your channel
this is such a huge accomplishment
stepping outside of your comfort zone
and making it happen is so amazing so
congratulations on getting started on
your podcast and if you did not hear
emily baker is going to be one of our
speakers this year at grow with video
live you can get your tickets right now
at the early word pricing if you're
listening to this podcast when it's
released
you can go to
growwithvideolive.com to see emily and
all of the other speakers that we have
for those days i cannot wait to see you
in person in may at grow with video live
thank you so much for listening to
today's podcast subscribe if you're over
on youtube or if you're listening over
on apple make sure that you know when
the podcast is coming out every single
tuesday so that you can listen when it's
released thanks for listening and we'll
catch you next time did you hear that
growth video live 2022 is back in person
this is your opportunity to network with
like-minded people just like you to make
friendships to make business
partnerships this is your opportunity to
get in the room you can get your ticket
now at growethvideolive.com
they're going so fast so make sure you
get your ticket right now at
growthvideolive.com
you